regardez ce que j'ai récupéré tout
nouveau produit de microsoft c'est la
microcentrale la surface laptop 4 13,5
pousser une super machine super machine
que je voulais absolument vous présenter
parce que vous connaissez de microsoft
sage rien vous apprendre complet de
choses et software du hardware & company
et en termes d'ordinateur c'est vrai
qu'ils ont des machines qui sont super
rebelle et celle là en terme de finition
en termes de légèreté en terme
d'expérience avec un écran tactile ça
apporte énormément j'aime beaucoup ce
produit je vous le montrez vous allez
voir il est super chouette et je compte
bien évidemment sur vous sur vous oui
sur vous sur toi car garde pour me dire
ce que tu en penses que vous en pensez
en bas directement ma dans les
commentaires non mais sans déconner
regardez-moi ça c'est super sympa super
bowl ce que j'aime ici déjà c'est la
finesse l'élégance est très très faim
c'est super beau ce à ce léger un tout
ce qu'on attendra d'un ordinateur de ce
poids là de cette envergure là c'est
super classe les finitions sont vraiment
super rebelle
microsoft a super bien bossé sur cette
machine regardez regardez
j'adore avec ce petit bise au lac est
dessinée retrouve légèrement mais très
légèrement sur le côté
oui on le voit comme ça à l'arrière
c'est pareil au niveau des aérations je
trouve ça vraiment vraiment chouette ses
fins et élégants ça sent la robustesse
super chouette elle regardera commencé
puisqu'on est la marraine et tous les
collectifs
c'est très marrant que microsoft ait
conservé ce choix là c'est d'être un peu
le le petit bémol c'est à dire qu'ici
vous allez vraiment un port propriétaire
pour venir recharger
vous prenez votre petit chargeur alors
il se prend il est monté se positionne
très très facilement donc ça c'est c'est
pratique ça revient très rapidement là
j'aurais trouvé ça va beaucoup mieux
qu'on vénère chargé en usb c est qu on
nous mettre en oeuvre le sbc de l'autre
côté parce qu'ici vous avez
effectivement assez peu de connectique
alors ça reste efficace de l'usb un peu
standard de l'usbc et une prise jack
ça aurait pu être bien d'avoir wcec un
usb c'est ici et gagner ce décès de
l'autre côté pour venir recharger en usb
c'est et de m'enlever cette connectique
propriétaire
je trouve ça vraiment intéressant de
venir me doubler les connectiques d'un
côté l'autre c'est un peu point négatif
à parce qu'en fait en termes d'usagé si
vous regardez sur un ordinateur est bien
ici vous êtes obligés d'avoir sur la
gauche vaut connectique qui arrive usb
usb ses prix ce diacre sur la droite
criquetot moins possible vous venez
uniquement leurs charges et sans nuance
en ce1 de pouvoir bien branché ici ici
j'ai pas forcément avoir toujours tu en
sais rien moi un disque dur sur la
gauche ou toujours vides à me connecter
des fois ça serait bien devant être
déporté à droite donc ça c'est un peu le
le seul regret est le seul point négatif
que j'aime me retrouver ici alors après
la beauté se situe à l'intérieur tu que
vous pouvez pas voir ni vous ni sentir
cette sensation c'est hyper fluide ça
s'accompagne super bien la charnière est
magnifique vraiment bien maîtrisé il
n'ya pas d'un coup il ya pas de saccades
on va jusqu'au bout regardez là il
touche pas ils suffisent bloque pas la
charnière est complètement dingos on est
vraiment accompagner ça c'est vraiment
génial alors windows et l'eau qui
déverrouille très rapidement qui me
reconnaît grâce à la webcam qu'on a au
dessus mais ça on en reparle dans
quelques instants le clavier super bien
et surtout une fois de plus on reste
dans les finitions
regardez la finesse du truc non mais
sérieusement ça c'est vraiment très très
bon ça sent la robustesse ça sent la
finition magnifique
autre point que je trouve vraiment
génial sur cette machine là c'est le
clavier là dessus aussi microsoft a
vraiment mis le paquet on est une course
qui est assez court qui est extrêmement
agréable
voyez une petite particularité assez
rigolote c'est votre touche fonction qui
est planqué en bas vous avez une petite
led qui vous permet de savoir si elle
est activée ou pas ça peut être pratique
allumées et éteintes
voilà j'ai un petit point de détail mais
à cette petite led là qui vous permet de
savoir est-ce que vous en êtes mon la
même chose qu'ici en fait retour de
touche vraiment agréable donc en termes
d'expérience pour venir taper ça arrange
bien on a une touche en plus en hauteur
qui est assez grande ici donc ça c'est
assez pratique par rapport à beaucoup de
machines où elles sont un peu plus petit
ici elle assez grand donc ça c'est cool
débord qui sont très fins autre point
qui est assez intéressant c'est le
trackpad arts le trackpad
il est à ce grand sens est trop grand
c'est vrai qu' on aurait pu s'attendre à
ce que le trackpad viennent encore plus
loin encore plus bas à fleurs être
encore plus grands voiliers bon c'est du
point dessus potache mais je trouve que
comme il est là il ya malgré tout une
harmonie qui est très bien respectée
très bien maîtrisée quand on prend un
peu de recul on voit qu'effectivement le
trackpad est quand même assez grand donc
en termes d'expérience c'est bien et une
fois de plus ce que j'adore c'est la
finesse des que le clavier qui m'ont
très légèrement comme ça qu'un petit
bisou vries sa part dans bye ça montrait
très légèrement sa montre comme ça pour
apporter un confort que vous venez tapie
donc en terme d'expérience en termes de
travail c'est vraiment une très très
bonne neige peut-être en point de
regrets
chose qu'on retrouve beaucoup c'est que
vous avez souvent des petits capteur
d'empreintes digitales pour venir
déverrouiller ici on l'a pas alors ici
on va venir tabler sur windows et l'eau
si vous n'êtes pas coutume et de windows
et l'eau voilà comment ça se passe vous
ouvrez vous mettez en face ils vous
reconnaît il des verrous tout de suite
et la session commence donc ça c'est
vraiment pratique alors après vous avez
deux écoles enfin trois écoles école
très standard vous n'avez pas de windows
lots plutôt rare eh bien vous venez vous
tapez un mot de passe pour déverrouiller
classiquement que ça fonctionne là vous
avez windows et l'eau grâce à cette
webcam et ça marche et ça fonctionne
bien donc ça c'est aussi très très cool
et autres points qu'on retrouve donc
beaucoup d'ordinateurs et je vous en ai
notamment parlé dans les derniers
ordinateurs de huawei c'est le capteur
d'empreintes digitales situé sur le
bouton de démarrage et là vous venez
vous prenez votre doigt vous poser sa
déverrouille alors ici ils ont vraiment
fait le choix de ne pas en mettre aucun
nulle part en terme d' usage très
clairement déjà comme il est là avec
windows et l'eau ça marche vous ouvrez
vous reconnais déroule très bien et si
toutefois ils vous reconnais pas parce
que vous avez un masque et bien vous
venez et vous tapez votre mot de passe
mais ici pas capable empreintes
digitales autre point qui est vachement
positif dans cette machine cet écran
tactile ça répond bien ça marche bien
vous allez sur internet vous ouvrez vos
fichiers faites ce que vous voulez ça
répond très bien vous prenez vous
déplacer ces réactifs ça marche bien
vous rétrécissent et vous rallumer vous
agrandissez vous faites ce que vous
voulez donc ça c'est très très cool
rosbank assez rigolo c'est l'audio
regarder si je pousse à fond
eh ben ça marche pas mal et ça c'est un
truc qui est pourrait paraître un peu
surprenant parce qu'en fait dans
beaucoup d'ordinateurs et bien vous avez
de l'audio kippa ouf
et j'ai vu dans beaucoup de pc l'audio
t'es pas toujours à la hauteur ici
l'audio franchement marche vraiment bien
les haut parleurs crachent très bonne
qualité s'associent un très gros point
positif pour venir regarder du contenu
des films des séries pour bien vous
faire du visionnage pour venir
travailler pour venir collaborer c'est
une machine qu'on pourra utiliser sur
des usages un petit peu mixte pour tout
ce qui va être collaboration
professionnelle visio caouette camier
plan clair ou alors on va pas voir ici
non plus les caméras les plus d'1 go on
et sur la petite webcam mais pour venir
faire de la visioconférence panis en
moins soit très bien qu'on un tracking
du visage alors maintenant il ya
quelques points un peu négatif si on
veut des points négatifs
et bien c'est regarder là au niveau de
l'écran oui parce que au niveau de
l'écran et vous le voyez eh bien on a
débord qui sont quand même assez grand
on aurait pu espérer un aurait pu
vouloir et par rapport à d'autres
produits du marché
on va pouvoir le retrouver eh bien on
aurait pu espérer avoir des bords un
poil plus fin peut-être une caméra plus
petit alors essaie des choses qu'on
retrouve un petit peu ailleurs débord un
poil plus fin pour permettre d'augmenter
un peu la taille de l'écran 10 minutes
et du chelsea c'est une fois de plus ici
du point de détail parce que d'un point
de vue global cette machine j'aime
beaucoup et j'adore les finitions mais
s'il y avait un point à améliorer je
pense que ça serait ça vraiment venir
réduire les bords pour laisser la place
encore plus belle un écran encore plus
grand et mieux mis en avant ici on a un
bloc de charge tout ce qu'il ya de plus
standard
on est sur lui 65 watts et d'un peu loin
on trouve aujourd'hui des 65 watts dans
le marché qui sont moins lourd que celui
là est aussi un point venir à venir
améliorer la par microsoft mais point
par contre qui et qui est positif et
bien c'est que vous retrouvez ici ça
c'est cool on retrouve pas partout et
bien de l'usb donc assez rigolo pour le
coup donc ça c'est ça c'est assez
marrant
est ce qui est super intéressant avec
cet écran c'est qu'ici vous avez un
format 3 2me le format 3 2me vous
permettra d'avoir plus de surfaces
utiles et notamment pour la productivité
maintenant le point un petit peu négatif
c'est qu'il va être plus grand que du
16/9 donc si vous regardez des films et
des séries bien nous est d'avoir des
plus grandes bandes noires sur le haut
et sur le ballon il ya deux tailles
d'écran qui existe 13 5 pouces et 15
pouces point qui est super intéressant
également si vous avez des micros de
qualité studio pour vos appels et pour
vos visions vous avez du wifi 6 du
bluetooth 5.0 et une autonomie qui est
quand même plutôt pas mal dans
l'ensemble vous avez un peu plus de ne
heures d'autonomie vous avez donc deux
configurations soit une configuration
avec un 13 5 pouces ou un 15 pouces
oeuvres et leur c'est super intéressant
parce qu'en fait ici en plus d'avoir
différentes couleurs
vous avez deux conflits au niveau des
processeurs vous avez soit un amd reisen
vous allez voir 5 ou 7 soit de linthal
corps de onzième génération regardez par
exemple édition de 13,5 pouces et bien
vous voyez que thor sur un âne der
heyden 5 4680 eu 8 gigas de ram 256 go
de stockage tarif de base est le plus
bas 1129 euro et après on va venir
monter dès que vous arrivez sur un intel
core i5 toujours la onzième génération
vous montre cette fois ci à 512 1449
euros et on va venir monter jusqu'à ici
avec un intel core i7 32 gigas de ram 1
tera de stockage à 2500 euros si vous
avez une deuxième configuration en 15
pouces aussi intéressante vous commencez
avec un amd reisen 7,7 fois 6 4981 eu 8
gigas de ram 256 giga de stockage à 1449
euros et on monte ici voyez sur une
ligne tels core i7 32 gigas de ram
intérêts de stockage de 1699 euros ce
qui est peut-être aussi un des points
négatifs de cette machine c'est cet
indice de réparabilité il est pas très
facile à ouvrir pas très pratique à
réparer 4,1 sur 10 autant dire qu'il
faut pas qu'ils n'ont pas de balle si
ton empreinte pendant la gare entier eh
bien vous changera probablement si c'est
après eh bien voyez qu'il est pas
forcément hypra hypra ils pratiquent à
venir est paré pour conclure c'est vrai
qu'on est sur une super machine moi
j'aime beaucoup une fois de plus ce qui
m'a vraiment frappé ici c'est tout le
travail qu'a fait microsoft au niveau
des finitions niveau du design d'un côté
extrêmement profilées ce clavier ce
trackpad de très très très belle qualité
il y aurait des petites choses
perfectibles notamment au niveau des
connectiques mais bon voilà ça
dépendrait plus de vous de vos usages
d'ailleurs est ce que ça pourrait
correspondre à vos usages est ce que le
fait d'avoir une seule prise usb à une
seule prise usb c'est tout ça déporté à
gauche ça pourrait vous convenir est ce
que le fait de ne pas en avoir à droite
est ce que ça peut être un problème de
la même manière le fait de ne pas
pouvoir chargé par la gauche alors vous
me direz c'est qu'un cadre qui vient
courir par ici mettez des femmes ont
tourné un peu limitées en termes
d'espacé c'est toujours bien de venir
optimisé donc ça aurait été bien d'avoir
de l'usbc d'un côté et de l'autre pour
venir recharger en usb c'est d'oublier
ce port propriétaire ici microsoft sans
devoir en tout cas aller dans le bon
sens dont c'est le premier reprendre le
même reproche c'est effectivement qu'on
pourrait aller plus loin
niveau de l'écran avec des bords encore
plus fins ce qu'on retrouve ailleurs et
qu'on ne retrouve pas ici c'est vraiment
tout ça du point de détail mais bon
voilà c'est une machine que j'aime
beaucoup je t'adore les finitions et si
vous cherchez un ordinateur portable le
plus compact mais quand même pas mal
pour pouvoir emmener facilement partout
avec vous et bien en terme de finition
cette machine là j'ai beaucoup à vous de
me dire ce que vous en pensez bien
évidemment en bas en commentaire est ce
qu'elle vous plaît vous botte est ce
qu'elle pourrait vous intéresser ou
alors pas du tout vous marquez tout ça
et si elle vous intéresse je vous ai mis
un lien bien évidemment en bas dans la
description l on se retrouve très vite
on continue à parler des clients plein
de choses qui arrivent donc ça c'est la
bonne nouvelle et c'est très cool d'ici
là des gros bisous des robes il joue
beaucoup d'amour pour le soin de vous et
à très vite
ciao